If only Mark Ruffalo had a time machine.
The actor who plays Bruce Banner and his alter
ego The Hulk is a notorious spoiler-spiller.
So, obviously, spoilers ahead!
In June 2017, Ruffalo inadvertently gave away
the ending of Avengers: Infinity War during
a Good Morning America interview:
"Wait 'til you see this next one — everybody
dies."
"Dude, dude!"
"... Not everybody.
No."
And in November 2017, he accidentally live-streamed
part of Thor: Ragnarok during the film's world
premiere.
"You gave away the whole movie, didn't you?"
"Well, only the first ten minutes of it."
And then, during his October 2018 appearance
on The Late Show with Jimmy Fallon, Ruffalo
revealed the title of Avengers: Endgame before
it was officially announced:
"I think it's out there already: The title
of the next Avengers movie is: [Beep.]"
It's worth noting that Ruffalo actually said
"The Last Avenger," but that didn't stop Endgame
co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo from posting
a tweet that read:
"Mark, you're fired."
Well, at least he kept his mouth shut while
promoting Avengers: Endgame, right?
Wrong!
It turns out Ruffalo actually did spoil Avengers:
Endgame several weeks ago, when he blurted
out a major plot point from the end of the
film.
In an interview with E! News alongside Captain
America actor Chris Evans and Nebula actress
Karen Gillan, Ruffalo revealed that the Russo
brothers had him shoot five different endings
for the film.
He also revealed that the directing duo never
gave him a complete script.
The actor said he didn't know the true conclusion
of Endgame during filming… and he claimed
that he'd have to wait until the movie opened
in theaters to find out which ending was ultimately
chosen.
Ruffalo explained:
"I didn't even get a whole script of this
movie.
I don't know why.
The script I did get had dummy scenes in it."
The story checks out.
The Russos have a history of withholding full
scripts from the actors, having done so with
Avengers: Infinity War to keep story secrets
close to the chest.
Anyway, at one point in the interview, Ruffalo
pointed to Evans and joked:
"He gets married in this!"
Ha… that's hilarious, right?
Captain America tying the knot in Avengers:
Endgame?
Like that would ever happen.
Except it does happen.
Though Ruffalo was offering an example of
one of the dummy scenes, he actually revealed
the real ending to the superhero ensemble.
Avengers: Endgame reveals that Steve Rogers
retires from being Captain America after returning
each Infinity Stone to their proper places
in time.
He chooses to remain in the past, reuniting
with his love Peggy Carter and growing old
with her.
Steve later resurfaces five years after the
events of Infinity War, explaining to Sam
Wilson that he chose to go back in time to
live the life'd always wanted.
When Steve shakes Sam's hand, we see a wedding
band.
Steve stays mum on who the wife is, but a
dance sequence between he and Peggy at the
end of the film proves that she's the lady
in question.
So, yeah — Mark Ruffalo totally spoiled
Endgame, but he probably didn't know he was
spoiling the film.
It sounds like Ruffalo's script was chock
full of fake scenes and he had no way of knowing
which ones were real.
Other actors in the MCU have been similarly
confused in the past.
Let's go back in time to Tom Holland's April
2018 appearance on Jimmy Kimmel Live while
the cast was promoting Avengers: Infinity
War.
Holland revealed that he didn't believe Spiderman
would ever wind up in an sci-fi tizzy with
Thanos:
"I was reading what I thought was a fake script
because it was like, 'Spider-Man's in space!'
So I didn't finish it, but I found out it
was real."
That's the catch-22 of the Russo brothers'
fake scripts.
They succeed in keeping actors in the dark
and keeping spoilers from leaking, but they
totally confuse the cast to the point that
they don't know what's real or fake.
Ruffalo clearly thought the idea of Captain
America getting married was too ridiculous
to be true, and he must've believed it was
a fake plot point that was okay to talk about.
Taking all this into consideration, we can't
place too much blame on Ruffalo.
Fingers crossed he doesn't get fake-fired
from the MCU a second time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.